well y'all looking good thank you
is this a group I see why I understand
why you guys created the music for lady
in the [ __ ] and it's such a classic
Disney film from the original do you
guys have a favorite scene I think my
favorite scene is Bella not a scene
where he know just the meatball over
yeah and it's that moment of sharing
this like Oh Cameron I want to give you
this it's kind yep bring you Janelle
mine had to be the cats oh yes yes the
cats have to agree yeah I understand
that you guys recreated the Siamese cat
song right because the original was
controversial it offended people sure
and you wanted to defend the culture
yeah yeah we wanted to be well they
wanted to be very sensitive today me
included how did you approach that
because it's such a classic film too
I mean the the intention of the scene
was that the cats come in make a big
mess and cause havoc yeah you can write
about that mean he's real a lot of
people experience that with their cats
so we just approached it with a lot of
fun and we figured that if we knew when
we started laughing then we'd probably
like reached a good oh yeah Janelle for
you being a part of this film what was
that like what is it like it's so
special because you get to do it with
people you love but these are like my
favorite producers and also there's a
cameo from my mom on lady in the trench
so we were all at the studio I wasn't
there they were all at the studio of my
mom came over in Roman it was working on
a lady in the [ __ ] working on the music
and you know just like getting all the
vocals together and she was there and
she is a dog's voice
let me tell you it is something she will
never stop talking about yeah she's on
there so that made it even more special
than I got to do this with family and it
was great to be in a film where Tessa
Thompson is the lead and she did such an
amazing job as being lady yeah last year
you were nominated for two Grammys
Grammy time is coming up do you have
anybody that you just would love to be
nominated this year I hope that lizzo is
nominated there's so much stuff she's a
friend and you know I we've know her
story and you know she's worked so hard
and she's been doing this for a while
and I think what she represents right
now she is an icon you know she's
bringing something new to the music
industry and that's important that
you're getting those those game-changing
artists who are pushing boundaries and
are being authentically themselves when
you can shine light on them that
encourages another generation of folks
to just embrace their uniqueness you
know what I'm saying so I think she's
important I love that
and lastly season two of homecoming with
our Canadian Stephon James yes Stephon
we are excited what can you tell us oh
my goodness well you guys are gonna yeah
it's it is it wasn't first of all was
just amazing working with Stephan you
know he is such a gentleman such an
incredible scene partner like his acting
chops like I don't need to preach about
that but he's so good and yeah this is
this is going to be some thriller
actions